the stakes are high this morning for
Democrats and Republicans and for the
American people as well Ed O'Keefe is
with us to discuss the potential impact
of these election results around the
country Ed good morning good to see you
guys of course so so what do voters on
both sides believe is at stake look for
Republicans today is about getting a
seat at the table they want the access
codes back to the room where it happens
that's what's driving so much of their
hunger and their turnout today they're
upset about the direction of the country
they're showing up to vote Democrats
understand losing full access to that
room means big problems potentially for
the White House and certainly for the
agenda that they've passed over the last
two years whether the convincing
argument has been made by President
Biden by all these Democratic candidates
remains to be seen well historically the
the party in power normally doesn't have
a good night right the Republicans I was
watching last night already seem to be
making plans yes so what does what's it
what's on the line for President Biden
here tonight well you know he and
speaker Pelosi I noted yesterday started
to concede at least some totally that
they may lose control of the house
tonight but Democrats are desperate to
hold on to the Senate and that would
make President Biden's life a little
easier if only for this it now only
requires a majority to get new cabinet
secretaries confirmed and of course
judges potential for Supreme Court
vacancies if one were to come up it
would be a lot easier for Democrats to
get somebody through if they still
controlled the Senate but they're going
to be bigger policy debates now if
Republicans they control the house over
basic government spending over the
future of immigration review of the what
happened in Afghanistan and
consideration of what to do about
Ukraine going forward in the future and
of course all sorts of other
investigations into the president's son
into how the covid-19 pandemic was
handled and the future of the economy
there's been big discussion about how do
you tackle inflation Republicans say you
got to cut government spending White
House and Democrats turn around and say
well then you'd be undoing everything we
just did yeah and then of course there's
a conversation about things like Social
Security and Medicare and the future of
abortion rights in the states and across
the country and I appreciate you I know
you got a long day long nights ahead but
aren't you excited about today election
I do too it's the day the viewers get to
stand up up off the couch and go say
something about what's going on let's
hope they do that that's right and
they'll be right here watching us CBS
News will bring you full coverage of the
election results beginning at 8 pm
Eastern right here on CBS